[Musique]
la transparence budgétaire
c'est la mise à disposition de
l'information bis j'étais un langage
simple accessible en temps opportun aux
citoyens
fait tout ce qui résume la transparence
budgétaire m l'information budgétaire à
disposition du citoyen que vous n'êtes
que nous sommes en son temps dans des
langages très facile et accessible
je vais commencer par vous dire que
cette démo peut sembler être nouveaux
mais au fait dans le quotidien de tous
les jours nous laisse nous les utilisons
transparence budgétaire
on peut l'utiliser ou à la loi ne nous
avons l'habitude de le côtoyer dans nos
foyers
dans nos maisons je donne un exemple
tout simple chacun de nous dispose d'un
budget familial n'est ce pas
mais qu'est ce qu'on observe souvent à
la maison quand les enfants ont besoin
d'acheter un petit pain écrivent et est
couvert moment moment j'ai besoin
d'acheter le pain moments divers le
garder dans mon sac et prend l'argent
pour aller acheter le pain mais quand il
s'agit des papas
il faut d'avoir la manière il faut
réfléchir il faut choisi son mot il faut
voilà mais il faut me mettre la manière
toutes procédures pour aller demander
les ressources familiales au niveau de
papa n'est ce pas alors même qu'un
moment décide ou bien à un besoin et
elle va vais pas perdre mon met elle
refuse à la dissolution de ta famille
pour acheter telle ou telle chose nos
chers et pour que j'adore ils ont cette
manière-là de tourner de faire un quart
de tous comme ça et souci un billet dans
un lot de billets et il retrouve sur
tous les toits surmonter tant le billet
tu as besoin c'est comme ça que ça se
passe n'est ce pas
alors production pour moi
ça voudra dire tout simplement que
avant que nous commencions pas
travailler sur cette thématique de
transparence budgétaire le budget
national était aperçu ainsi comme ça
pour venir pour avoir ces à
l'information budgétaire il y avait deux
manières des procédures il fallait aller
voir ils étaient destinés à des gens à
des élites à des sachants et tout le
monde n'avait pas assez et même quand le
remettait tu ne savais vraiment pas quoi
faire alors on en était là et un beau
matin après 2015 on nous annonçait que
le bénin est évalué par libé pelli bpc
logan au plan international qui s'occupe
de la notation pays dans le monde entier
sur cette thématique transparence
budgétaire
et on nous attendait la note de 1 600
e km
1 600 l'avons reçu comme choc on s'est
dit mais comme tous les pays du monde
nous élaborons notre budget
comme tous les pays du monde nous
exécutons le budget mais pourquoi est ce
qu'on nous donne une autre de 1 6 1
alors on a cherché à savoir pourquoi en
2016 le gouvernement a demandé
avec l'appui du partenaire technique là
j'hésite on a demandé à la dgb et à la
société civile de six réunis pour faire
diagnostiquer et nous aider à identifier
les points d'attention les points de
faiblesse sais tu n'a pas fonctionné
dans notre politique budgétaire ou que
nous ayons reçu cette note de 1 600
alors ils se sont mis au travail
et on a compris en fait que notre
politique budgétaire au niveau du bénin
en ce moment là n'était pas inclusive
ça voudra tic
nous élaborons annan et un budget
peut-être de dix minutes je dis un truc
mais a fait damner l'exécution la
mayonnaise jamais les 100 %
on n'atteignait pas le taux d'exécution
normal qu'ils étaient de son cousin ça
veut dire que chez moi à la maison je me
donne comme objectif
d'investir mille francs dans une dans un
âge dans une acquisition dans un dans un
dossier chez moi et à la fin je n'arrive
pas totalement réalisée ou bien
atteindre l'objectif que je me suis fixé
moi même mais cela est dû à quoi
c'est dû au fait que le budget ne
prenait pas en compte les vraies
préoccupations du peuple
notre budget ne mettait pas le le
béninois le citoyen ne contribuait pas à
la halle à l'élaboration de ce budget là
et ne participez pas non plus aux
échanges que nous ayons post obligé
pendant et après et au cours de
l'exécution du budget on faisait les
programmes de développement entre nous
avec des objectifs qu'on s'est fixés
mais on associer pas le bénin le citoyen
dans cette thématique là alors le
gouvernement a pris la résolution de
faire des réajustements
des réformes institutionnelles
ça les a menés alors à créer à l'unité
de la direction générale du budget
une unité dédiée à la transparence puis
j'étais
et cette unité est chargé de piloter
déjà
la feuille de route pour l'amélioration
de la transparence budgétaire parce que
quand on a fait le diagnostic soul avec
le soutien de l'ag z ça fait et y en
avait découlé une feuille de route
cette feuille de route et mis à la
disposition de l'unité et on a essayé de
répertorier toutes les actions à mener
pour améliorer la transparence
budgétaire au niveau de notre pays ce
amener ça nous amène chaque année
à mettre à la disposition du public
toutes les actions que nous pensons
menées au cours d'une année
pour améliorer cette transparence là et
ça nous le publions sur notre site web
on a commencé par faire des réformes
l'unité a été compartimenté en poules en
quatre poules principalement il ya le
pôle société civile pour la collectivité
locale pôle statistique et planification
et puis le dernier pour s'occuper de
notre relation avec les ministères
sectoriels le bénin est évalué par libé
p cette institution ad l'homme qui sont
exigés pour chaque pays dans ses
standards exigés pâli bp et avait
l'élaboration de huy document en plus du
budget on élaborait oui documents à
mettre à la disposition du public les
documents
en plomb le premier c'est le budget
citoyens du projet de la loi des
finances
ça je vais je vais expliquer un peu le
projet de la loi de finances pourquoi
son budget citoyens sont obligés
citoyens parce que c'est ce projet qui
est déposée si la table à l'assemblée
nationale c'est la table des députés et
c'est autour de ce projet qui a eu
quatre souvent des échanges et à la fin
on a le vote du budget qui devient
document de l'exécutif que nous
exécutons en année n donc il faut
nécessairement simplifiée l'information
pour que les gens aient accès à
l'information
pour pouvoir agit en son temps et en
temps opportun surtout sur les les
aspirations du gouvernement pour le
peuple en année qui va venir mais ce que
vous connaissez le budget quelqu'un a vu
le budget une fois ici
le budget c'est déjà la loi de finances
qui est souvent moins dé 100 pages
mai
à cette loi une ânesse
des documents 14
essais de gros documents
si on remettait ce document un béninois
qu'est ce qu'il va faire de ça c'est
fait tu ne peux pas qu'est ce que tu
peux comprendre d'un document il faut
être praticiens des finances publiques
il faut s'y connaître une fréquentation
mais si je ne sais pas ce qui a contenu
dans ce qu'on peut me fait pour
améliorer mon quotidien comment
pourrais-je pas les aider le
gouvernement à mieux aller dans le sens
que je veux pour avoir les résultats ça
va être difficile donc c'est très
important d'élaborer le budget citoyens
du projet de budget qui est déposée de
le fait enlever sciences citoyennes
quand diversion citoyenne ses versions
des agrégés simplifiée accessible
lisible par tous et compréhensible par
tous
mais on a fait plus ça c'est ce qu'on
nous a demandé de faire nous au bénin on
a apporté des innovations à ce niveau là
quand on a fini de faire on est confiant
que au bénin notre population en
majorité analphabète
mais film sache ils ne comprennent pas
le français nous avons rédigé le
document français qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire on a décidé alors de traduit
d'abord d'élaborer une version
simplifiée en vidéo du budget général de
l'état et ça c'est une pâtisserie tobin
ça n'avait jamais été fait nous n'avons
plus 1,5 en 5 secondes vous suivez la
vidéo vous comprenez ce que c'est que le
budget est ce qui sera réalisé passe est
en année en cours
nous avons essayé de faire cette vidéo
là et on l'a fait on l'a déclinée en
neuf langues nationales
il y en a c'est partout c'est un oeuf
langues nationales et c'est publié
partout vous allez sur le site web de la
dgb du ministère des finances du
gouvernement vous avez la vidéo et c'est
en ça permet en moi dans mon village de
comprendre un peu ce que ce qui sera
fait pour moi l'année qui vient ça me
permet de 10h au moins la maternité
qu'on n'avait pas là l'état pensent à en
construire bientôt et là je fais le
suivi déjà mon niveau est-ce que c'est
fait monsieur le maire est ce que vous y
pensez et ça ça s'est pas amélioré le
fonctionnement
c'est pour améliorer les conditions de
vie de nos citoyens n'est ce pas
quand on a quitté la veille citoyenne du
projet de loi des finances
on réalise maintenant après tout ça
quand on fait tout les échanges ont voté
le budget on fait le même exercice le
budget adopté et on fait sa version
citoyennes ont fait la vidéo pour qu'on
est maintenant à la rippe à la
l'atterrissage ce qui a retenu pour être
exécutée en années qui virent donc on a
voté le budget en fait s'avérer aussi
tué l'ont fait la vidéo on fait le
traditionnel national nous élaborons
également ça fait le deuxième document
en troisième document sait
les rapports d'exécution du budget
vous avez en fait entendu on a élaboré
le budget on l'a votée mais c'est beau
après on vit encore durant la borsa
c'est pas la nomme la norme exige qu'en
coup de dés édition on vient de rendre
compte de là où nous sommes de ce qui
est fait par trimestre est de ce qui
sera fait ce qui devrait être fait et
puis là peut être qu'on n'a pas pu faire
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne l'a pas fait et
quelles sont les dispositions qui sont
prises pour pouvoir le faire avant la
fin de l'année et ce document ne
rappellera pas d'exécution du budget au
cours d'une et nadine année nous
élaborons quatre rapports un rapport par
trimestre donc quand ça s'ajoute aux 12
ça fait 6 nous avons encore de rapport
au passage tous ces rapports nous
faisons le bestiau site web donc
influent français désagréger pour
permettre à tout le monde de comprendre
après ce si rappaz le 7e c'est le
rapport en cours d'année le rapport aux
cours d'année ça permet d'évaluer
le budget qui est en cours d'exécution
est ce que ça marche
est-ce qu'on n'a pas eu des risques
exogènes comme on a eu en 2019 la
pandémie kobe 19 qui est venu bousculer
les ressources est-ce qu'on a pas eu
d'imprévus qui empêchent le bon
déroulement des activités prévues donc
on essaye d'évaluer pouvoir est-ce que
nous sommes sur le bon chemin pour qu'en
décembre on exécute le budget tout au
moins à hauteur de 90% pourquoi pas donc
ce sera paul a donc ça nous permet de
nous jauger au fait et à le dernier
rapport que le rapport en fin d'année
mais le rapport en fin d'année que nous
allons nous élaborons en 2021 c'est le
rap adam de fin d'année de l'année
passée le de l'année précédente pourquoi
parce que on a institué toujours dans
cette réforme on a donné comme
obligation à tous les ministères
sectoriels
d'élaborer le rapport annuel de
performance
saveeasy que chaque set chaque
ministères sectoriels élabore un rapport
qui évalue le niveau d'exécution des
politiques publiques de son secteur en
année en cours donc ce sera paul à izon
l'obligent à terminer l'année avant de
commencer sa relation donc l'année se
termine en décembre donc à partir de
janvier ira dans ce processus et c'est
validé et quand ils finissent tout ça
ils nous envoient donc c'est en année en
année en cours on élabore ce rapport le
rapport de fin d'année de l'année
précédente donc là nous avons les ouïes
drapeau n'est ce pas on pouvait s'en
arrêter là mais vous savez le benetton
ne fait jamais les choses comme ça on ne
fait jamais les choses comme ça
le gouvernement de mon pays a pris
conscience qu en mettant la société
civile au coeur des politiques publiques
qu'ils avaient tout à gagner
que ça allait l'aider à mieux conduire
les politiques de développement
alors on a on a innové on a apporté des
innovations
si l'ensemble du processus on a d'abord
développer une relation de choix avec la
société civile et ça je les remercie au
passage pascoe béni on a la chance
d'avoir des sociétés civiles à ces
structures est bien organisé par
thématique et papou donc il nous aide
ils ont compris que le gouvernement
travaille pour améliorer les conditions
de vie des citoyens et que eux mêmes à
côté du gouvernement ils ont des soucis
organisé qui contribuent aux mêmes
objectifs
donc ils peuvent collaborer et awa de
résultats enfants parce que l'objectif
est en commun aller ensemble menée par
les produits ne devrait pas constituer
un problème nous avons cette société
civile à on a développé une relation où
et
quand ils ont des
crises observe sur le terrain des
dysfonctionnements il enfin rapport et
nous saisissent
et quand on reçoit le document on sait
on s'empresse de les lire et de voiliers
cherché à savoir si ce qui est dedans
est vrai si ce qui est dedans bettina et
comment est ce que nous allons faire
pour améliorer ce point d'attention qui
est soulevée à notre attention donc
chaque fois ils nous font des rapports y
en a des rapports alternative des
rapports nous ne prenons pas au niveau
du gouvernement comme des documents qui
critiquent les actions du gouvernement
au contraire vous l'avez intégré dans
notre processus et nous essayons
d'écouter de lire pour améliorer ce que
nous sommes en train de faire donc ça a
été vraiment la tête du gouvernement et
et on les reçoit le ministre le bourg
tout le monde les reçoit à divers
niveaux et on le retrouve les potes on
est même allé jusqu'à avec les
ministères sectoriels leur permet
d'assister à la revue sectorielle qu'on
a institué on a institué au cours d'un
ministère au lieu d'exécuter le budget
tout au long de l'année qu'ils aient des
revues périodiques et au cours de ces
revues la société civile assiste les
ministères sectoriels et partager avec
eux leurs points de vue qui qu'on reçoit
et qu'on intègre dans les documents de
politiques de développement
donc c'est tout ça mais je vais vous
allez vous demander pourquoi la
transparence pourquoi l'état s'intéresse
à la transparence budgétaire pourquoi
est ce que nous donnons ce mal à régler
à respecter tout s'est tu nommes
quentris est transparent tout le monde
est content vous savez vous allez voir
observée ces dernières années que tout
le temps pas la notation le fmi est venu
noté tel pays nous a noté et vous allez
aussi entendre d'un autre côté que le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
va souvent sur le mile le marché
financier et qu'on mobilise des
ressources qu'on le lève des fonds si
aujourd'hui on arrive à faire tous ces
exercices aussi facilement c'est parce
que nous avons travaillé les réformes
instituée par le gouvernement actuel a
permis de planifier ou bien de
d'éclairer les ressources budgétaires et
on a une visibilité de ce qui se fait à
la base donc sa racine investisseurs si
je sais ce que tu fais avec mon agent
quand il me dit prête ou moi là je vais
te prêter parce que je sais de quoi je
te remettre j'aurai le résultat est le
résultat est là visibles vous comprenez
donc c'est ça donc ça participe déjà la
mobilisation des ressources quand je
suis citoyen et je quitte chez moi
aujourd'hui avant moi je faisais une
heure ou deux avant d'aller au bureau
mais aujourd'hui j'ai fait dix minutes
quand c'est comme ça et l'état me
demande je veux collecter les impôts j'y
vais avec empressement parce que les
impôts collectés je sais ce que ça fait
dans le pays voisin
c'est pour vous dire que la transparence
budgétaire c'est tellement important que
qu'un gouvernement inscrit d'enfer la
mobilisation des ressources fiscales
devient très facile
parce que l'état à l'adhésion de la
population à fait politique de
développement la population le sang ce
qui se fait au quotidien avec les
ressources de l'état vous avez vu nous
donc ça c'est comme ça mais aussi sa
d'autres
avantages que nous voyons pas et que
c'est là où vous était venu
ça devrait la transparence budgétaire
devrait nous amener à développer en
chacun de nous laver citoyenne quand je
dis la veille citoyenne c'est à dire que
moi aujourd'hui j'ai dit que avant je
faisais déjà aujourd'hui j'ai fait dix
minutes pour aller au bureau ça me dit
que je suis je suis un enfant gâté déjà
avec la soie tâche première phase mais
si j'ai la chance de bénéficier dans mon
quartier de la première phase de la fat
âge je devrais veille à ce que personne
ne vienne
creuse est un tout si la voie qui passe
devant ma maison les talibans qui sont
devant ma maison convient de jeter des
ordures je dois tout fait lutter au
quotidien à ce qu'on ne vienne pas usé
ça parce que si je le fais je permets à
d'autres béninois de mai de bénéficier
de ces mêmes sefra suture parce que
c'est le cas de biens et la veille
citoyenne me permet de préserver tout ça
dans de bonnes conditions
l'essai d'autres benhima les ressources
que l'état au rabais a mobilisé cette
année serviront à fait d'autres choses
pour d'autres baignoire dans d'autres 7
n'est ce pas donc ça c'est très très
très important c'est important pour nous
que vous sachiez le contenu que chacun
de nous chaque citoyen cherche à
connaître le contenu de la loi des
finances cherche à savoir ce qu'on a
prévu pour lui dans son secteur et pour
répondre à tout ça vous n'allez pas
souffrir
la réforme nous amener à élaborer des
plaquettes d'information
quand je suis du monde du 7e je suis
étudiant apprenants il ya une plate est
dénommée plaquettes éducation que nous
élaborons un loup public on vous prenez
cette plate est déçu et a déjà toutes
les actions prévues pour le secteur de
l'éducation
enseignement supérieur jusqu'à la
maternelle vous avez ça et vous avez une
idée de quoi vous attendre de ce qu'on
doit faire pour votre set et ça vous
permettre de faire le suivi puis j'étais
il ya aussi une plaquette est celle là
permettez moi de raconter son histoire
passons en 2002 le premier
gouvernementales ont ce qu'ils se
disaient c'est le gouvernement n'est pas
social le gouvernement n'est pas social
et un jour du retour de l'assemblée
fait jusqu'ici était tellement ça s'est
tellement j'étais con à 10 mai et si
c'était vrai
et si c'était faux
et on sert le ghana d'y arriver au
bureau on va essayer de prendre le
budget est d'essayer d'identifier les
actions qui épate le 7 et social mais
quand nous l'avions fait on s'est rendu
compte que le social était un niveau
imaginé par nous mêmes
on a dit donc c'est parce que les gens
ne savent pas quelles sont les actions
qui impacte le social qu'on peut dit ça
on a décidé alors d'élaborer une
plaquette des mesures sociales du
gouvernement que nous élaborons chaque
année on élabore au niveau de projet du
budget et du budget adopté parce que
c'est une plaque est très importante ça
permet aux gens de savoir qu'est ce qui
est fait que s'il doit être fait dans
leur quotidien dans leur vécu nous
élaborons succès de plaquettes nous
avons aussi une plaque est spécial
enfance avec notre collaboration avec
l'unicef on élabore une plate est qui
retrace les les ressources allouées 17
heures la mère de l'enfant pour
permettre à nos dames
d'avancé et sur ce coup là c'est pour ça
c'est un exemple de la collaboration
avec la société civile tu joues c'est on
est l âge où ils nous ont dit qu'ils
avaient des relais communautaires les
relais communautaires et les bonnes
dames que nous rencontrons dans nos
villages et qui est de nos moments à
comment élever assister les moments dans
les accouchements
et que les assistés à préparer les
premières pas donner les premiers soins
au moment donc c'est l'unicef qu'il est
recruté et qui les paient qui le mettait
à disposition de l'état mais le
programme a fini et qu'on a été saisie
notre mini s'est mis à table avec le
ministre de la santé ils ont travaillé
et on a pu dégager les ressources
nécessaires pour faire rouler comme le
terrain et aujourd'hui on a même
amélioré ce programme le gouvernement en
a fait à tout un programme à part et
c'est aujourd'hui qu'ils sont dans nos
villages dans nos amours et qui assiste
nos parents pour faire les premiers
soins la pandémie qu'ovide ils ont
contribué ils ont fait les
sensibilisations partout c'est ça les
résultats que nous avons cotisé avec
notre collaboration avec la société
civile maintenant vous allez me demander
mais quel est le gain je commençais pas
dit quand on nous avait noté insu sans
ça vous avait choqué quand on a mis les
réformes en place quand on a commencé
par respecter les normes les standards
internationaux en matière de
transparence vie j'étais qu'on a essayé
de faire les choses de rendre le budget
plus transparent de d'élaborer d'abuser
inclusive nous avons gagné beaucoup de
choses par exemple aujourd'hui la loi
des finances exécuté pratiquement 100 %
en année en cours
à 100% pratiquement
pratiquement sensiblement son cousin en
tout cas on a toujours des rapports
d'exécution en fin d'année qui sont au
tout entre 90 et 95 et 100 % c'est ce
que nous avons aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
nous avons gagné
à la dernière évaluation
le bénin a été nommé champion d'afrique
francophone en ma cuillère et francfort
ah oui si on veut un peu plus s'il vous
plaît
champions on est premier en afrique
francophone où si cette thématique de
transparence qui j'étais parce que non
seulement on a fait ce qu'on nous a
données on a respecté la publication
dans des délais donnés vous savez la
publication ses dents avec des délais
parce que l'information est une denrée
périssable
quand tu ne donnes pas l'information la
personne au bon moment ne peut rien
faire avec
quant à respecter tout ça toute cette
procédure on apporter des innovations
comme des vidéos auquel personne n'avait
jamais fait dans le monde tant a fait
tout ça on n'a fait que là on a mis en
place
la collaboration avec la société civile
on écoute les gens on va nous mêmes v e
ça on est devenu premier en afrique
francophone pour la transparence mais
j'étais tout ça pour vous dire que la
transparence budgétaire
c'est c'est une exigence de notre
constitution
la transparence budgétaire le droit à
l'information est consentie par la
constitution de la république bis est
renforcée par la loi sur la
communication
donc c'est un devoir de mettre
l'information budgétaire à la
disposition du public et ceux de voir le
gouvernement at il le fait si bien
tout ça pour vous et que quand on est
transparent tout ne va pas bien mais au
moins on sait où on va et on a des
objectifs on se fixe des objectifs
on se donne les moyens de les suivre et
chacun de nous doit pouvoir faire les
2,6 à la maison merci de votre accueil
[Applaudissements]